this film just kind of jumps into it and
I'm gonna do the same here wad and and
ask you about your training is we meet
you here you're just kind of in it
you're filming everything but what first
drew you to filming and I understand
you're pretty much self-taught yeah as
12 just the fact that there's not a lot
of people who are really journalists and
can can be in the same place where we
where as activists so we just felt that
this is kind of the responsibility that
we have as well as we protesting but
also to document this minutes which is
from the beginning was like it wasn't I
had no idea about what I will why I will
use this footage but I know that this is
just important and that's like
continuing with me the whole time until
the last minute of the film all the time
that I have that idea that I will not be
survived and like every minute it's the
last minute so I should just keep
filming and keep gathering this footage
hopefully that one day someone will like
take this footage and make something
with it Edwards can you tell us a little
bit about your personal background with
Syria and what compelled you to want to
make a film about it well I've been
making documentaries for 12 years about
all sorts of different complex tones
around the world Afghanistan Yemen
different places but when the Syrian
Revolution started it just felt that
that was something completely different
in the sense that in Syria what you had
was people like these amazing two people
here fundamentally middle class educated
secular people who were peacefully
protesting for basic rights and values
that we would take for granted and they
were being met with the most horrendous
and ferocious military force the full
military power of a nation-state and
they continued peacefully protesting for
months and months and months and
watching from afar I just felt this was
an extraordinary moment in human history
really a moment of great courage and
great dignity on the part of the Syrian
people and so yeah so I just really
wanted to make a film about them but
this
my first opportunity to I tried to do it
I was stopped at the border a couple of
times I made a film about Isis but it
was really this I felt like all the work
I've done was building up to the moment
of meeting these two and supporting word
in particular and Hamza as well to tell
their story and do justice to her do you
remember the first footage that you saw
of what she had shot and what may be
struck out to you is this is gonna be
because there have been plenty of
documentaries made about places that are
experiencing crisis but very few that
are done like this just the the
genuineness of it and the intimacy of it
yeah I mean some of her stuff had been
on the news already so like two of the
scenes that appear in the filmed three
brothers was the first thing I ever saw
of her footage and I think that was a
moment when just people minds around the
world were blown basically because not
only was it such a terrible story but it
was filmed with such tenderness an
emotional connection and sort of beauty
and realism and yeah it just in that one
scene it really brought home the
conflict I think so many of us and that
was all thanks to her but there is
something different and I think what
makes this film so different is that
it's it's your experience as a mother
and it's those scenes not only with your
child but the other children when did it
kind of become clear in your mind that
that was the perspective that you wanted
to take in this documentary that it was
for sama when I was shooting that I had
no idea about like what I will do with
this footage or at that time also he
wasn't had any connection with anyone
outside like to say that I'm doing this
and not doing this so I was just like
keep filming and capturing these moments
and feel the the I was just trying to
really see how I will how I'm feeling
this and how I really wanted just to be
captured so during the time as any mum
mum around the world I when I had when I
was pregnant I was speaking to to my
daughter when I she was like just one
month or three months I was like
speaking with her as an imam around the
world
and the scene when I was like telling
Hamza and the [ __ ] I'm pregnant
it's I think every mom has some kind of
this crazy things about how she will
tell her partner about that and I just
felt that this myth is really important
for me even if I wasn't an ape oh but
when I wasn't a limpet it was like much
much much higher as a feeling and then
when we were after I left and then I met
Edward and we decided to work this firm
together and 2/3 from the Brooke process
when we decided that the best films like
should be something really different we
started as a chronologically way to
understand the story and even for me
because I was too involved from the
beginning until the end and even we've
we've just left one or three months from
Aleppo so I was also like very emotional
related to the story so when when we
decided about like making - for summer
we were just thinking about how we can
something Edward always saying and I
will steal this from you yeah
he was always saying like something like
the material will tell you what what
it's one to be the film will speak to
you
but it just takes time until we will
understand that and it takes just like
two years not so much but it just it was
really clear after we decided it's all
before summer you've seen that
everything was like coming around the
idea because like suddenly it's just
what it should be began from the
beginning how much can you talk a little
bit about what you hope this film will
bring to people living here in this
country what you hope they'll take away
from it
like the first and most important thing
for everyone that will see the story and
hoping that it will might change the
narrative about the the Syrians who are
in Syria like having a conflict now
inside Syria or the Syrian refugees this
this story is still happy
on daily basis in the last three months
more than 26 hospitals were targeted in
at depth and yesterday 53 people were
killed in one city in also close to to
ad-lib called martyred in the cold
market nah man so and I think nobody
heard this in the news because in the
narrative that we had that the ISIS has
ended and the war against Isis has
finished and Syria now is safe place so
everybody can just jump in and go back
and that's it while the situation as you
have seen it's not like this a it wasn't
Isis was like a very like brutal and an
evil part of the situation in Syria of
course but it wasn't all about Isis and
hoping that by by sharing this this
story some time but one day like maybe
one government might take a stand and
bring justice to to the people maybe not
in the near future but maybe like it
will I believe that accountability will
happen and justice will will happen one
of the things that I think we all hope
as well that people take away and
speaking as a British person I think
it's very easy for people in Britain and
America you know and in the West I guess
to look at places like Syria and say oh
that's happening to the other you know
it's sort of or the Middle East there's
always war there's always chaos like
nothing can be done and you know you
wring your hands but feel that somehow
we can sit in our countries and say well
it's terrible what's happening over
there but you know we're over here and I
think what you see when you look at
Syria you begin to realize that the
things in our countries you know the
effect on our politics that when you
think about what the refugee crisis and
what Isis have done to our politics
which are affecting us now that all
flowed out of Syria and fundamentally
you know our failure to kind of support
our fellow human beings who were
suffering in that way and I think that
is one of the big things that we hope to
take away is the fact that we no longer
live in a world where we're okay
they're not we have this shared humanity
we have this connection between us all
and we're all in it together basically
to try and make our world just you know
to turn turn it around I guess from this
dark period we're going through to see
this extraordinary reaction and we've
taken it all around the world we took it
to can we've taken it to Nantucket we
took it to Sheffield it's gone to Munich
and we've had this reaction positive
reaction everywhere and it really just
gives you hope you know that people they
still care like we were told that
fatigue would be you know everyone's
like oh yeah exactly as you said like
people are done with Syria and you know
they've seen it all and whatever but
these guys stories and what word
captured in her camera has just got this
force to punch through they are
inspirational Edward watts and word and
Hamza al-khateeb thank you so much